[Música]
cuántos de ustedes han sentido que
intentan algo una dos tres veces son más
y no lo logran
a cuántos de ustedes les ha pasado como
a que el equipo de fútbol
que año tras año temporada tras
temporada llega a la final perdón la
gana
quizá ya sepan en qué equipo de fútbol
estoy hablando no quiero mencionar
nombres pero siempre visten de azul
qué pensarían si bien esta frase se
buscan nuevos líderes de méxico y fuera
una convocatoria y ustedes como
estudiantes postularían les gustaría
aplicar no hay más información es la
única información que ustedes tienen
y los requisitos
a mí me pasó esto yo lo vi en quinto
cuatrimestre de la facultad de
ingeniería química y decidí postular
como les mencionaba esta convocatoria
salió en el 2015
yo estaba en quinto cuatrimestre
desgraciadamente le dé importancia a
otras cosas y falle desde el primer
momento no termine de registro la
primera etapa y la fallé por
consiguiente fue rechazado
2016 misma convocatoria al menos ya
había un panorama anterior a esta
convocatoria que había un año que había
sucedido por lo mismo ya sabíamos de qué
sucede de qué iba a esta convocatoria
yo estaba más interesado presta atención
y decidió postular
en el séptimo cuatrimestre
qué creen realizó el registro en línea
completo ahora sí lo termino desarrolló
un ensayo realizó exámenes de
conocimiento y de habilidades
tengo la etapa final llegó esta etapa la
etapa final dos entrevistas online
realizó las entrevistas y muy seguro de
mí mismo digo me fue bastante bien
llega el día de los resultados descargo
el archivo pdf nunca lo olvidaré
empiezo a ver los nombres
y qué pasó no estaba a mi nombre que
había sucedido puse todo el empeño y
nuevamente no lo había conseguido
fui rechazado
el último año para postular 2017 porque
último año noveno cuatrimestre estaba a
punto de egresar era mi último periodo
en la universidad y era un requisito
indispensable ser estudiante activo
nuevamente pongo atención a mis errores
veo que sucedió mal
postuló terminó la registro en línea
desarrolló mis ensayos desarrolló este
vídeo realizó la última etapa mis
entrevistas nuevamente digo no fue bien
sin embargo ya tenía la espinita de que
no había quedado
dije último año última oportunidad
ante el día de la selección nuevamente
descargo el archivo pdf
y que creen
de buscar pongo mi apellido concha
y afortunadamente esto me los
seleccionados
que les quiero decir con esto
fallen pero aprendan a fallar fallen
bien están en la universidad están en
esta etapa en la que pueden aprovechar
fallen incluso con elegancia pero
aprendan de estos errores
el segundo año que yo postulé pedía
retroalimentación y yo mismo me la di y
porque sabía que si no hacía algo no iba
a poder quedar en todo el periodo que yo
estuviera
posterior a ello me di cuenta justamente
la frase del principio el mundo está
lleno de especialistas yo he decidido
ser erudito en este programa tuve que
desarrollar cuestiones sociales y
cuestiones de inmigración claro no lo
desarrolla a un nivel experto pero sí
aprendí de ello ustedes que sean en la
universidad busquen aprender de ello
busquen desarrollar nuevas habilidades
y obviamente sientan esa motivación
sientan esa persistencia busquen la
excelencia a diario
aristóteles lo decía de una mejor manera
una manera fenomenal la excelencia no es
un acto sino un hábito buscamos eso
buscamos que nuestros actos diarios se
conviertan en habilidades y estas
habilidades se vuelvan hábitos de esta
manera podremos alcanzar la excelencia
día tras día
el segundo punto que quiero contar con
ustedes es este la vida está llena de la
vida está llena de oportunidades pero
generalmente son retos para combatir
esos retos en oportunidades necesitamos
tres resistencias la resistencia física
la resistencia mental y la resistencia
emocional
yo en la etapa universitaria decidí
desarrollar estas tres habilidades
y encontré un lugar donde puedes
desarrollar estos tres puntos justamente
es una montaña una montaña te exige
estas tres resistencias entonces yo los
invito ir en este caso a la malinche
vayan conquisté la cima
e la malinche como les comento visite
algunos lugares fue con amigos expertos
era mi primera ocasión que yo visitaba
una montaña y fue la malinche fue con
mis amigos que ya habían visitado lugar
y llegué a este punto el arenal es el
punto de mayor exigencia mental en la
montaña porque
como podrán apreciar es una pendiente y
está llena de arena también tiene rocas
pero rocas que no sabe si están fijas o
no en la montaña entonces si tú las
tocas puedes deslizarte y si pisas en la
arena por cada paso que des la montaña
se encarga de regresar te medio paso o
más entonces necesitas tener muy claro
tu objetivo esa cima
esta es otra perspectiva en el arenal
en este arenal yo recibí un gran
aprendizaje
como a mis amigos expertos en el tema
decidí seguirles el ritmo tratar de
adaptarme a ellos sin embargo como yo
nunca había ido nunca había ido a una
montaña nunca había visitado alguna
montaña no tiene experiencia en ello
nuevamente un chico inexperto
y por seguirles el ritmo me pasó esto
me lastimé
acá y rhodes sobre las piedras del
arenal
me lastimé piernas rodillas codos y
desde esa línea la corrupta vertebral
todo en un momento de esa atención y
desesperación
que les quiero decir con esto en la vida
sentimos justamente eso sentimos que no
avanzamos como el arenal que regresamos
sin embargo si tiene muy fija la meta
podrán alcanzarlo
de hecho platicando con liliana mejía
directora operativa de una de las
empresas más importantes en méxico me
decía este busca un objetivo un
propósito mayor a ti de esta manera
tendrás una guía en el horizonte
está aquí en el horizonte puede guiarte
tal cual a tus objetivos y qué tal si lo
fusionamos con esta frase de alejandro
bird de fernando birrí perdón
la autopista en el horizonte en cada
paso que des la utopía se alejará un
paso si yo camino dos pasos la utopía o
el horizonte o en este caso el propósito
de ustedes que es mayor a ustedes mismos
se alejará dos pasos entonces para qué
sirve la utopía para qué sirve este
horizonte sirve para eso para caminar y
de esta manera buscar una excelencia
el último punto que quiero tocar con
ustedes es justamente de mi periodo como
estudiante en web de hecho todas las
historias han sido mediante mi periodo
de estudiante en web
esta historia surge cuando yo en este
programa que ingresé que tardé tres años
en entrar
preguntan quién es de la benemérita
universidad autónoma de puebla
yo levante la mano al igual que ustedes
y no saben qué orgulloso me sentí estaba
representando a la universidad éramos
dos jóvenes en ese periodo nada más y
estábamos poniendo la cara por la
universidad
ello es importante ustedes que son
estudiantes en este momento
siéntanse pertenecientes a la
universidad sientan se pertenecientes a
ese objetivo mayor a ustedes ya sea como
tal la universidad un equipo de trabajo
un propósito pero sigan sigan ese
horizonte levanten la mano cada ocasión
que pregunten por él puede ser
cuestiones tan importantes como el
cambio climático o incluso cómo regresar
la humanidad a la humanidad que hoy nos
hace tanta falta
este sentido de pertenencia es el que
quiero que desarrolle este sentido de
pertenencia a un objetivo los hará
caminar
como la utopía como esa cima de la
montaña como el horizonte búsquenlo
aférrense el y creen sus objetivos con
base en ello afortunadamente este
programa salió bien y tuvo oportunidad
de estar con el rector esparce
tuve oportunidad de platicar con él y
justamente demostrarle lo perteneciente
que estaba de cuat
en ocasiones que tengan ustedes 23 años
futuros presenten sea una entrevista
laboral a un programa un intercambio a
lo que ustedes busquen pero presenten se
orgullosos de su propósito presenten se
orgullosos de su universidad si ustedes
aportan a cualquiera de estos objetivos
créanme que ellos van a aportar para
ustedes con retroalimentación y con
crecimiento personal y profesional
nadie de nosotros de los que nos verán
en este círculo el día de hoy ha llegado
aquí sin fracasos pero tampoco tiene
apoyo de alguien más
entonces agradezcan a cada persona que
cree en ustedes que los apoyan tengan
esa humildad y también nuevamente
atreverse a fallar estar en esta etapa
fallen a lo loco pero fallen viene
fallan aprendiendo de ello
l quiero dejar justamente estos tres
puntos la pertenencia la persistencia y
la perspicacia
si se sienten pertenecientes a un
objetivo mayor a ustedes ya les decía
cambio climático medio ambiente o
incluso regresar la humanidad a la
humanidad
porque ustedes quieran incluso a la
misma benemérita universidad
tendrán ese objetivo ya tendrán esa guía
en el horizonte que pueda guiarlos
caminen con ella la persistencia
justamente es para no dejarla
para caminar que sea ese motor que los
obliga a caminar día tras día y vuelve a
un hábito diario de esta manera será una
excelencia tal cual lo decía aristóteles
y por último la perspicacia como en la
montaña no puedes pensar cualquier
piedra porque porque hay piedras que te
van a ser resbalar hay piedras que te
van a hacer caer y trata de visualizar
un futuro desarrollar un plan y ve con
ello ustedes que son universitarios
aprovechen este tiempo desarrollen
proyectos desarrollen cuestiones y todo
enfocado a este propósito vamos a
cambiar porque no a la universidad
porque no a méxico creo que todos
tenemos esas habilidades no por nada
están aquí buscando singularidades del
genio
vamos con todo y sin embargo sin duda
vamos a buscar un beneficio para cada
uno de nosotros porque vamos
representando en sí a un periodo más
grande a la humanidad gracias
[Música]